exploring the unintended consequences of
a safety-first culture through the lens
of a quarantine was to me a a really
interesting rumination because we can be
a safety-first country but only for very
very very short periods of time and then
we're reminded that the chief goal of
living is not to merely stay alive I'm
Dave Rubin and this is the Reuben report
we're still in lockdown mode joining me
today is a true renaissance man an
author a podcaster a narrator and a guy
who has done an awful lot of dirty jobs
micro finally I can welcome you to the
Reuben report and finally I could say
it's great to be here I'm sorry it took
so long but you know jobs stuff that was
a big intro that I gave you there
because there's a lot of things that I
could call you I suppose or that someone
reading your bio could call you what
what would you call yourself first and
foremost
a good-natured model to vocational
schizophrenia
that's not bad um when I uh
you know I I mean it's such a huge
question really I mean it's just you
came right out of the gate with a giant
existential query you know how do I
actually how do I actually identify
myself for a long time I would have said
I'm a host and then I went through this
phase where I said well I get paid to
impersonate hosts on television shows
and I became fairly facile at it but
today honestly thanks to Dirty Jobs and
a bunch of other stuff that happened in
its wake
I've I've adapted the mindset of of a
guest part guest
avatar part cipher so
I see my role today not to be too grand
about it but I tapped the country on the
shoulder from time to time and say hey
what about him
or what about her or get a load of this
so it's a I'm a curious guy with the
number of platforms that allow me to
indulge myself at every turn
all right well now that we got the
existential stuff out of the way I'm
good I'm gonna stroke your ego for a
second and then we'll get into the other
stuff so I didn't tell you this in the
minute or two that we talked before the
cameras turned on but when when the
first episode of Dirty Jobs came out I
saw it and I was like do you remember
what jobs you were doing in that what
job you did in that first one by any
chance well there's the there's the
first one that aired and they're the
first ones we shot and in my back yeah
the the very first dirty jobs to air
featured me in a bat cave Bracken cave
outside of Austin Texas
40 million Mexican free-tailed bats in a
very contained creepy a horrific place
literally wading through guano as these
bats hung upside down defecating
urinating and giving birth a little tiny
placentas showering down upon us as
domestic flesh-eating beetles living in
the guano crawled slowly up our woefully
inadequate Tyvek suits to dine on our
happy flesh so you got the answer
correct and the reason I know that is
because I saw the very first episode of
dirty jobs and I went on like the
official dirty jobs message board this
was before we were all tweeting and all
this stuff and I wrote something like
this Micro is completely insane this
show is crazy it's amazing I couldn't
stop watching and guess what micro
responded to me that very night you were
on the message board on the Dirty Jobs
message board and you responded to me so
this is not the first time we've
communicated well then let's just say
well it's seared into my retina Dave
I'll never forget that night I was in a
motel 6 I was alone no it it's it's so
fortuitous looking back because I'm a
late adapter I didn't do the Facebook or
the Twitter in fact I said to Jay Leno
and somebody posted this video not long
ago I would rather I would rather stick
hot needles in my eye then tweet or book
a face or said I'm just always always
always late
but but the Discovery Channel in 2003
said listen if we're trying this thing
and we'll build you a chatroom and I
said if you call it the mudroom call it
the mudroom and I'll go in it that those
early days talking with fans literally
and from Motel sixes and super eights
and just you know shoot the [ __ ] with
people in the middle of the night really
form the foundation not just for the
show and my interaction with the people
who watch but the program itself the
show was programmed from that chat room
all of the ideas after season one came
from guys like you sitting up too late
you know sending off illicit texts and
whatnot but there you go there you go so
we have communicated before I will try
to keep this in the same level of
respect that I communicated I'm sure
anonymously on an odd chat board so
there there it is okay so before before
we do anything else there's a million
things that I want to talk to you about
but we're in this strange coded time
obviously we're both in California not
in the same town but we're both here in
California where it does seem like we're
gonna be one of the last to open up and
we've got a lot of kind of big
government officials here that seem to
be at least from my position encroaching
on our rights at this point
well first off I guess just what's your
take on the lockdown specifically maybe
a bit about California since you live
here and then I want to talk about
getting back to work and the importance
of working and things like that
sure sure I am
I've been comparing it to the
kubler-ross five stages of grief right I
mean the country's grieving in a sense
but we're all at different levels and
we're all grieving at different speeds
and we're trying to process a lot of
information and a lot of data without a
ton of context or perspective and so
what you wind up getting with that in my
view anyway is the opportunity to look
around and go oh look he's in denial and
he's bargaining and she's depressed and
she's angry and that was accepted it but
what have they accepted exactly have
they accepted in reality the virus the
reality of the lockdown or this weird
space that requires us to somehow
navigate both and so I early on wrote a
piece
called safety third which borrowed the
title from a special I did for discovery
back in 2008 where I ruminated on the
unintended consequences of a culture
that truly elevates safety to an
unrealistic place on some hierarchy the
safety first culture the safety first
mentality with regard to vocational work
is is fascinating because it's rife with
unintended consequences when you when
you put safety at the top of the thing
and when you tell your employees or your
customers they that their safety is your
top priority you set the table in a very
strange way and it's a way that often
times in my view anyway fosters
complacency among the very customers and
employees who should be really taking a
measure of personal responsibility for
their own actions
so exploring the unintended consequences
of a safety first culture through the
lens of a quarantine was to me a really
interesting rumination because we can be
a safety first country but only for very
very very short periods of time and then
we're reminded that
the chief goal of living is not to
merely stay alive at least not not for
most people and then this fascinating
conversation starts to unfold so that's
a long way of saying that for the last
60 days or so I've seen a lot a lot of
conversation right around a couple
topics that I love specifically
homeostatic risk compensatory risk risk
equilibrium and all the subconscious
things we do to maintain our own
illusory relationship with the illusion
of safety so let's talk about those
types of risk a little bit cuz you've
worked with a ton of people who take all
sorts of crazy risks in their day to day
jobs all the time do you sense that
maybe we've hit the limit at as we enter
sort of now two months or roughly eight
weeks of lockdown that we've sort of hit
the limit where now it's like okay we
did what we had to do but what I'm
sensing at least here in LA where you
know it's pretty lefty people are
willing to accept you know a lot of
government but now when I'm walking my
dog my my neighbor's you know they're
suddenly going we gotta be outside now
like it's 85 and sunny why am I not at
the beach right now that that's
something I'm not even talking about the
people that have had their lives
destroyed and lost jobs and everything
I'm talking just but sort of the regular
people who walk around in a sort of
dazed about what reality is all the time
but even they're starting to tilt now
are you sort of amazed that the way we
don't look at risk normally until
suddenly it smacks us in the face well
yes because look we're just not used to
it yet and part of the reason we're not
used to it is because it's just a
staggering new thing to get your head
around but it's also hard to get used to
a thing when the goal posts are
constantly moved when the data is
constantly shifting and most of all when
the experts themselves are in violent
disagreement this is the most
disconcerting thing to people and and
I'm sure you've spoken about it there's
one of them in that same article that I
wrote early on was this idea that I mean
here's Neil Ferguson right
he's very very clear in his projections
and his modeling and here's John ionise
down at Stanford and he's saying look I
just don't I'm I'm looking at the same
data I'm not disputing the data but I
just don't think it's reliable and these
two big brain guys you know once
predicting 80,000 fatalities in this
country the others 2.2 million
somebody's not just wrong somebody's
very very very very wrong yeah so you
know when when you look at that
through the lens of a fake news culture
where sources are inherently unreliable
and where everything is politicized you
know it's not unreasonable for the
average American to look around and be
skeptical you know and it's and it's not
unpatriotic to want to look at this
thing from all sides and kick the tires
and to your question we're creatures of
visual stimulation you know we take our
cues from a thousand different things
that happen around us all of the time
and you're right when the Sun goes out
and the breeze is warm and and it's like
this is when we're supposed to be doing
XY and Z but we can and we don't because
time is somehow bent and I don't know
but I mean it's it's it's been hard for
me personally to concentrate I thought
when this happened I was gonna sit down
and take a few months and write I love
to write I write mostly on planes now
finally I have a chance to do this I
can't it's all I can do to get my
podcast up once a week now and uh and
part of the reason is because I'm
genuinely curious to to stay informed or
at least try to make sense of the next
deal it's like somebody's dealing the
cards Dave and they just don't stop they
just keep coming yeah and you think
they're playing one game and now you're
in a completely different game it's back
to the stages of grief everybody is
always starting over and trying to
figure out where they are and when 330
million people are doing that
contemporaneously it's a hell of a thing
yeah I love that analogy because it's
not only as if they're playing with
unlimited cards but it's also that you
don't know whether you're playing poker
or some other game or they're gonna flip
it in the middle or something else like
we're just sort of stuck in this endless
thing so then how does a guy like you
who has a pretty I assume you consider
yourself someone with a pretty high risk
threshold I mean how do you decide when
you have to now start taking risks and
going out either with or without a mask
or just just not listening to whatever
that as you described we have this fake
news thing out there when when you're
not going to listen to the narrative
anymore
well this is the it's the eternal
paradox because the honest answer in
normal times to your question is is
deeply personal risk isn't personal
right this is why risk compensation is
so interesting you know 100 people in a
room everybody has a slightly different
tolerance for risk and when you
introduce when you introduce protocols
safety features for instance the theory
goes that your behavior will change
to suit the measures you take prisons
if you wear a seatbelt studies show you
drive faster if you wear a helmet on
your motorcycle
studies show you corner faster the more
safety features you put on a machine the
more likely the operator is to assume a
level of risk that is slightly
heightened why because there's a there's
a thing in our brain that wants to keep
the risk homeo in a in a in a
homeostatic state right so Rhys risk
equilibrium is the thing that says you
subconsciously adjust your behavior to
adapt to your circumstances was
perfectly rational but as you start to
introduce new safety protocols
subconscious things start to happen why
for instance are the most dangerous
intersections in the world the ones that
have the crosswalks and the little guy
telling you when to walk in part it's
because it trains us to look at the
little guy walking and when we see him
walking we step off the curb and then
the Big Blue Bus
takes us out right because we've been
trained not to look so something is
happening right now with regard to
public safety and individual
responsibility
it's a collision and on the one hand
you've got a lot of people like myself
and probably you who think I'm gonna do
this when I'm comfortable I'm gonna take
the risk that's no more risk when I'm
comfortable and when my equilibrium
rebalances on the other hand were being
told by our employers when to come in
we're being told by the state when to
stay home and for how long and now in a
thousand other little ways we're being
told sometimes by being scolded other
times by being shamed in whatever way
shape or form the mask is going to
become a dog whistle it's it's it
already started to I walk around my
neighborhood half the people don't wear
masks half are those who are the waves
of disapproval are coming off of them
and they have science and research and
they have proof to show me why I'm being
irresponsible well the maskless crowd
has their experts and they
their research and so it goes and it's a
my answer to your question is I don't
know other than to say that we can't
completely arbitrage personal
responsibility out of the equation yeah
arbitrage is the right word there that
was a good word and it's exactly the
right one there you know I don't want to
get myself in any trouble here but my
hair is a little shorter than it was two
days ago do you know what I mean
you I I'm not saying I'm taking I think
what you're saying is you invested in a
Flowbee and spent some quality time
alone you ever Flo be yourself it ain't
easy my friend I now know that place
this morning
ok so the main question that I think I
wanted to ask you that I think will sort
of frame everything else we're gonna
talk about is that there seems to be a
narrative out there from a certain set
of people that it's like Oh going back
to work it's just too risky and no one
really wants to work anyway and you know
aoc had some version of this sort of
thing like only in America would we
value work so high and as a guy that I
have seen do the craziest jobs you know
where you're stepping in [ __ ] your hands
in this animal the bats electricity
water you can give me ten other examples
of the crazy things that you've had
people do you work with people who would
do this for a living can you just talk
about just broadly like the importance
of work relative to finding purpose in
life relative to just setting up the
rest of the things that you want out of
life because that actually is one of the
things that I'm most worried about right
now that as we sort of give away our
day-to-day lives that we're gonna forget
that work is important not I'm not
talking about slavery but I'm just
talking about the getting up with
something to do because it makes you
some money so you can do everything else
with your life that you want to do so
it's the frog in the boiling water
I share your fear it's not gonna happen
like a light switch though what's the
old poem not not with a bang but a
whimper and the way it'll happen here is
people like aoc and others who genuinely
or maybe not so genuinely believe that
work is fundamentally another expression
for drudgery are going to make those
points they're going they're going to
reduce it to something that's purely
transactional that's that's the first
step and if you only look at what you do
as a means to make money then I then
then then you're not an interesting
person okay it's just
it's such a one-dimensional way to look
at something that should in my view and
oftentimes does define us you know it's
our work it's a it's it's the thing we
choose to do with the most conscious
chunk of our life and so to reduce it to
a paycheck is dumb obviously there's a
giant transactional element involved in
it but there's so much more dirty jobs
happened because because I couldn't
follow in my grandfather's footsteps
which I very much wanted to do my pop
was a guy who could build a house
without a blueprint he only went to the
seventh grade but he had the the chip
right in his brain that he could take
your watch apart and put it back
together blindfolded he could he could
build a house he could run pipe he he
was a master electrician steam fitter
pipe fitter mechanic architect all of
that well he was heroic in his youth in
his time
for those things today he'd be a mr.
Sullivan you know he's transparent and
so many of those trades so many of those
those vocations have fallen into into
this gap between blue and white collar
they've they've lost their luster and
we're simply not properly gobsmacked the
way we used to be about the miracle of
modern plumbing or the miracle that
happens when you flick the switch and
the light comes on so so dirty jobs was
meant to be a tribute to my grandfather
initially and it was and then it became
a rumination on essential work which is
interesting right because obviously the
headlines have have have caught up with
that and that's really been my great
good fortune over the years I do average
shows with low production value but big
beams and I stick with those themes and
every couple of years the headlines will
catch up with them dirty jobs and the
people we featured became weirdly
relevant when the economy crashed in
2009 and it's become weirdly relevant
this month I've been on every talk show
there is to talk about essential work
and it's funny I'll tell you what
happens I mean look there's a there's a
poster I keep it on my wall to remind me
I put a pig on a pedestal many years ago
for a lot of reasons and people have me
on they expect me to to make the case
for essential workers and of course I do
because everybody understands that case
now when dirty jobs went on nobody was
making that case so I felt special and I
felt like you know iconoclast out there
saying hey don't forget about this one
in this one this one right now
while I still hold them in the absolute
highest esteem I'm amazed at how we've
taken 35 million people and beamed them
on essential that to me is something I
reckon we're gonna look back on with
great linguistic embarrassment because
that bet that's exactly what I wanted to
ask you next so God continue continue no
it's you're different that I just really
do know what that was that was the
question really like when once we say to
35 million people you're not essential
it's not just about the job that they do
it's it's the message that's getting
across to their lives which in some ways
I actually think in some ways if they
can get through it and then rethink what
they do maybe there is something else
they want to do but I don't think that's
the message that most people are gonna
get I think we're gonna leave people
with some sort of existential crisis
we're doing it it's part of the grieving
process I was saying earlier people are
coming to terms with the fact that their
vocations don't matter in the eyes of
virtually everyone who has a show to
host because in our
in our well-intended enthusiasm to
celebrate the essential workers we've
done a thing we always do with the
language and I am I am NOT a politically
correct person at least I try not to be
but language does matter a lot and you
know in my own foundation when I feel
most comfortably in my own lane I talk
about education and the skilled trades
and higher education is a turn of phrase
that has become inculcated and when we
talk about the importance of higher
education well who would doubt it of
course we need big people with big
brains doing important work but what
what does higher education imply if not
the existence of many forms of lower
education subordinate education so the
language bakes in a terrible kind of
analysis if you don't get a four-year
degree if you don't buy into the idea
that the most expensive path is the best
path for the most people then you wind
up doing something they don't call it
lower education because that would just
be crazy but they call it alternative
huh we have some alternatives for you
Dave maybe you'd like it over here in a
trade school or perhaps you'd be
comfortable over here in a community
college or in a fellowship or an
apprenticeship so we did that in
education and the unintended
consequences are breathtaking we're
doing it now with the very heart of
people's identities and we're doing it
around the simple word we're not meaning
to do it but you watch it's it's gonna
come back over the net with a lot of
topspin people are already pissed off
about it I just don't think they quite
understand why yeah let's actually back
up for a second and talk about your
foundation a little bit because
everything you're saying right now I
think does get to a trend that I've been
seeing for a while which is I've had so
many guests who come from academia and
you know so much of our national
conversation is about outrage culture
and cancel culture and what's happening
at college is and now because of
YouTube's average people and I mean that
in the best sense of average all of us
can can watch incredible thinkers give
lectures you can watch Jordan Peters and
lectures on YouTube
for free and maybe get more information
from that then you can from a semester
that you're paying 25 grand for so talk
about your foundation and and sort of
can you just relate that a little bit to
what you see happening with higher ed
relative to if you have a trade right
now it's like you are essential again in
the best sense of essential that's not
we're not putting down the non-essential
maybe we can come up with a better word
for it right now well we should because
everything has a season and part of the
reason we're locked in this endless
feedback loop of nonsense is because
we're in love with cookie cutter advice
and so we dispense it with certainty and
this is what politicians do to be
elected they have to they they have to
say the thing that's going to resonate
with the most people and so they wind up
they wind up retrenching two bromines
and platitudes and tropes that's what
safety first is that's that's why Cuomo
said no measure no matter how draconian
or drastic could be deemed unjustifiable
if it saves a single life reasonable
people reasonable people know that's a
lie reasonable people know that when
United Airlines or American Airlines
says here at blankety-blank airline your
safety is our priority we don't really
believe that because seconds later they
invite us to strap ourselves into an
aluminum tube and defy gravity at 700
miles an hour okay the truth is on the
back of the ticket rules of carriage
read that and you'll hear the truth so
we don't tell people the truth in a lot
of ways but when we lie to them now
the consequences are catastrophic so
we've got to get past the cookie cutter
advise the bromides in the platitudes if
there's a silver lining to answer your
question and I think there probably are
a couple of them I don't know when we'll
see them but the way we learn surely has
to be among them what we're doing right
now I mean the opinions will vary
obviously but this is meaning no no you
know you know everyone's on board what
we're doing right now trust me I mean
you were having a grown-up conversation
I don't feel rushed to provide you with
a soundbite you're you listen more than
you talk which most guests most hosts
don't do so you know you're you're doing
a bunch of stuff right and two weeks ago
I watched on YouTube a lecturer from MIT
for free the same lecture that would
have cost X thousands of dollars right
so I think when the dust settles higher
education is going to be revealed for
the luxury brand that it truly is and
when you take away all of the stuff that
has nothing to do with learning or
connecting you're gonna be left with a
breathtakingly overpriced product and
when you look at schools like Harvard
who didn't refund their the the tuitions
for canceled classes they didn't even
refund the room and board you know well
people are gonna get used to this screen
they already are but I think more and
more are gonna take deeper dives into
more interesting ponds and they're gonna
find big thinkers with easily accessible
ideas who are exponentially more
interesting than professors and soon I
hope our
obscene love affair with credentialing
is going is going to stop and we're
we're going to pause in every imaginable
way and look at what is essential not
just in workers or in work but in
education and food and fun you know
everything is going to be forced through
a different filter and I wish I were
smarter to say specifically you know how
that's going to come out but um you
never get to see how the sausage is
truly made you know in our industry
really or in or in any until the dust
settles so we've got to get through it
but I don't know that we're gonna
recognize the airline industry I don't
know that we're gonna recognize higher
education I don't know that we're gonna
recognize exercise everything is going
to change some things for the better
some things not but that level of
uncertainty through all of it is the
reason why everybody's walking around
like an extra in the walking dead right
now waiting for clarity yeah so even
though we maybe didn't want this I'm
pretty sure nobody wanted this to happen
but to all of your points that lead to
the silver lining of this do you think
that in a weird way this was almost
necessary to get like it almost feels
like the old world was just sort of
caught in some weird I guess the Frog
and the pot kind of thing like our
institutions were not working properly
we know how much money we were sending
kids out into the real world with debt
that the jobs weren't quite there that
if anything maybe this toppled enough of
the of the just the grunge and grit that
was on the machine maybe it chipped off
enough that we can start building some
new stuff so that's actually good I
think so look I I liken it to
I mean every major transformative moment
in your own life was probably preceded
by something akin to a splat sometimes
things have to go splat you know
sometimes in little ways sometimes in
big ways um this is a biggie this is the
biggest thing I've ever lived through in
terms of a uh you know a
transformational event um and so I again
I I don't know how it's going to shake
out but but yeah the machine just got
shook we just something grabbed us by
the lapels with big muscular hands and
shook really it's still shaking us and
we're we're trying to make sense of the
shaking while our glasses are flying off
of our head and the change is coming out
of her but we're still being shook but
here's the here's the thing I mentioned
this I think - Glenn Beck the other day
you know the thing nobody is thinking
about when with regard to a premature
opening versus and unnecessary
sequestration is what happened to the
Brits in 39 right I mean Hitler dropped
a lot of bombs on London every day day
after day day after day after day for
weeks they stayed in hunkered in the
bunker in the air-raid shelters and then
about three weeks into it they started
venturing out bombs were still falling
right started opening shops the bombs
were still falling they opened the
schools the bombs were still falling
they were cleaning up now I'm not saying
for a second that we ought to do
anything premature but I'm saying that
no matter what we do first is going to
feel premature doesn't matter what it is
it's going to feel reckless it has to by
definition but the thing is what really
drove the Brits out of their bunkers
I I wasn't there I don't really know but
from what I've read my sense of it is
they got bored looking at it got bored
of being terrorized
just said no and and they had enough
time as horrific as it was they had
enough time to let it sit for a minute
and let there's no way you're coming out
after day 2 or 5 or 8 or 12 14 mmm 20
mm-hmm right and so it's very personal
and there's a herd mentality just as
surely as there's a herd immunity and
the first ones to go
we'll look reckless and crazy but then
others will follow and then pretty soon
you're a guy who gets behind the wheel
of your car and drives across the state
knowing full well that 40,000 people are
going to die this year as a result of
traffic fatalities but you get in and
you and you strap up and look you do a
lot of things I mentioned Cuomo earlier
and I'll circle back if you really
believed it if you really believed it
then you might not get together just get
together with the governors and say look
we're lowering the speed limits to 20
we're all wearing helmets and we're
outlawing left turns you could say
40,000 lives this year but you won't do
that because we have baked the risk into
our lives and at base we are a safety
third kind of people we know that there
are other things more important safety
always is the rational thought but I
think really not to make it all about me
but I was right in 2008 safety first is
a bromide and that platitude it sinks in
to the point where a lot of us believe
it reflexively but we don't really
believe it and we are right now waking
up to the fact that we've been living
with all forms of attendant risk for a
very very long time
just not used to this and it's gonna
take a while to get used to it but we
will and if getting used to it means
masks and temperature checks and cavity
searches or god knows what else I don't
know but there will be protocols and
they will be accepted and we will get
used to them just as surely as we're
used to taking our shoes off the airport
is the x-factor of all of this though
that while in you know 1930s Britain you
know they had newspapers that were still
being delivered to their house that
we're all in our house being under onto
a different type of onslaught which is
an information onslaught and as you said
are sort of our journalists class and
our protected academia class whatever
that is it's getting almost impossible
to figure out who to trust these days
that you may know I'm in the midst of my
my first book tour right now and one of
the questions that almost everyone has
asked me so I probably been asked this
about a hundred times in the last week
is Dave who do you trust and I'm running
out of good answers on that like I can
pick a couple people that I kind of
trust but I don't really trust
institutions I wouldn't just say the New
York Times certainly you know what I
mean that we're under another type of
attack in a weird way that it's not just
what what is actually happening or
what's not happening is that there's a
constant narrative being slammed at us
from whatever your preconceived notion
is you know Mike Shermer right of course
he's what he's one of eBay I had him on
two weeks ago he's one of the best know
best
I've never met him give him my regards
how's he I will he's great go to pork
ears I'd that'd be terrific I'd love to
meet him cuz he he did write a book
years ago that had a huge impact on me
it was called why people believe weird
things and it was such a simple look I
was fascinated at the time with with
with clubs and groups and organizations
and cults and passwords right all of
that stuff you know and I had some
friends who had been in my view
inculcated and and this business of
deprogramming people and talking to
people rationally that he was the guy
that really got me most interested in in
thinking that way so you know the answer
to your question is to be is to be
skeptical without being cynical and
we're living in a time of great
confusion I think and great cynicism and
we we shouldn't
shouldn't forego our our skeptical
nature in order not to be well look we
need to be skeptical is the answer we
need to trust and verify and we need to
we need to question our own assumptions
I think first and foremost we we we
can't simply preach to the choir as
pleasing as it is to do so we need to be
challenged we need to be out of our
comfort zone but but we also need to be
honest look I thought I haven't read
your book yet but I read your first
chapter and I'm looking forward to
finishing it but you're right about
coming out you know in a in a really
honest way and you and coming out
politically in in so many ways I suspect
as probably you know more difficult than
it's ever been and so sorry I'm free
associating but but to be skeptical of
your own truth your own beliefs I mean I
don't know about this own your own truth
thing never really resonated with me but
but to be skeptical not just about what
you believe but why you believe it and
then you know to share that skepticism
requires a measure of humility and and
that's what I liked about what I've read
of your book so far you you can't be
enlightened without being humble and you
can't be humble without being wrong what
station are you people I assure you I've
been wrong a couple of times and it's in
public but but to be wrong and not be
humbled by it is to is to have a quality
that is not not what's the word good it
is not good to have the capacity to be
wrong but not humbled is that it's it's
the beginning of the death of shame see
I know you're not part of the academic
class there because you went into the
depths of your mind to find the right
adjective and you came up with good my
second favorite four letter word yeah
exactly
all right so let's back up because a lot
of the stuff you're giving me
sort of jives to me as someone that got
a decent upbringing that got some of the
right things handed to them and since we
just had Mother's Day just this past
weekend your mom according to this paper
in front of me is a two-time New York
Times bestselling author her last book
it's from two weeks ago she was on the
list I might be on the same list as your
mom which would be pretty spectacular
tell me a little bit about your
upbringing your relationship with your
mom how she sort of stepped into this
she's just she 82 now she's 82 I think
and has she's 82 and has sort of stepped
into this other life as if what you were
doing kind of wasn't enough
it's the well it's it's the most
enjoyable thing I've ever watched and
it's probably the best thing I've ever
done in terms of being a son you know my
mom and I are very close sir my dad and
I and she's been writing me stories for
years we critique each other's work she
writes me stuff she reads it and so
forth a couple years ago she wrote a
very funny story about losing her purse
at the local Walmart and the hilarity
that ensued is my father who doesn't
hear so well didn't have his hearing
aids and was trying to call her phone
that was in the purse and was dumpster
diving it was pandemonium like pee your
pants funny I read it on Facebook and I
posted it and I went to work and two
days later I came home and 71 million
people had watched the video of me
reading my mother's story now this is
where it goes off the rails publishers
call and they're like Mike if your mom
and write a couple dozen of those she's
got a book and just make sure you're in
them so we have a hook right we need the
the mother gotta have the hook so I say
mom here's what you do we need 20
stories I got to be at him she says oh
gosh that's terrific but you know
Michael I have two other sons
like mom look it's not about them it's
about your book just do it your Jude
okay she goes away she writes this book
about my mother I'm not in any of these
stories they're 30 stories about my Nana
my grandmother now they're hysterical
but nobody's gonna publish them so I
printed 10,000 copies put him out on
Facebook sold out in two days then the
publishers called and said oh my god you
didn't tell if she could write so they
reprint her first book and she just
finishes her second book about your
father and other celebrities I have
known Peter pants funny that's the book
that's on the list right now and it's
just a few dozen very funny essays she
wrote to me over the years about the
incredibly odd quirky and brilliant man
that is her husband my dad and you know
of course she writes this very funny
book at the height of the plague and it
falls to me to try and promote it around
the same facts yeah yeah ii-i've been
watching you man it's really been fun
because you're all we're not all in the
same boat but we're all in the same
storm right and we're playing the cards
we have and we're trying to sell our
books I'm trying to help my mom and it's
just I mean how much more adaptable and
this is a compliment to the species but
you know you're seeing people adapt
right now to this entirely new world in
in every imaginable way and regarding my
mom's book she's 82 and completely
become a new person I'm 58 and now
saddled with marketing her book in a way
that hopefully works in the age of
Corona all the rules are gone everything
is different and while that's unsettling
it is uh I don't know what do you I mean
are you weirdly liberated by all that
suddenly possible well it is weird
because as you know this is this is my
garage and I'd love to get you here
sometime because I can show you some of
the dirty jobs we had to do to make a
garage in LA with our regulations here
work as a TV studio but look I
supposed to be on a book tour right now
I was supposed to be going across the
country I think I was in Grand Rapids
tonight you know like that that's where
I was supposed to be now you can't even
plant seeds in Grand Rapids that's a
whole other thing with there the the
governor over there but but yeah like I
one of the things I'm most interested in
you may have heard me say is a couple
times but like the people who bore me
the most right now are the people who
just view the world through politics
like I'm really interested that's why I
think what you've been doing all these
years is so interesting because it was
like obviously you have like some
political ends on the world but it's
through its through the work that you do
or the people that you meet that's way
more interesting to me than just the
people who are like Democrats this
Republicans this you know so those Bowie
I don't want to get off your the topic
of your mom for a second because as we
talk about this hey my mom yeah whether
whether you want to or not but you know
there's been this whole thing about you
know people of a certain age now with
corona and all that so as you watch your
mom at 80 to find this career now in a
way you're kind of like working for her
what do you think it's actually done for
her I don't mean in terms of sales or
celebrity or any of that stuff but what
do you think is just done for like an 82
year old woman to like be able to put
something into the world at that age
that's just relevant and and sort of
probably needed right now I mean there's
probably a reason it's selling has
something to do with we could use a
little humor these days right well look
what's I mean in our world what's what's
more gratifying than moving the needle
in a measurable way blast ratings right
whether it's the ratings for a podcast
the ratings for a show the sales of a
book we're just a letter from somebody
who says Dave you know I read your stuff
and now I'm thinking differently I mean
that that is truly transactional right
then I mean that matters and and my mom
at 82 gets I I think yesterday she got a
thousand notes from people all over the
country you know just saying Peggy I I
read your book and and I saw my husband
in it I saw my sons in
I saw my mom you know in a really kind
of Miss Marple
Erma Bombeck meets Betty White America's
grandmother you know just Impala honest
it makes your teeth hurt way has somehow
somehow found a way to move the needle
with millions of people and so you know
to do that in the prime of your career
is gratifying to do it in your 82nd year
is a consummation devoutly to be wish'd
she's done it and in doing it she has
inspired a lot of other people to sit
down and running people who would
otherwise never try it I just think it's
I mean it's it's amazingly important and
I'm kidding aside I'm grateful that you
brought her up because I think I think
we need to find people you know whether
it's our mom or whoever people who are
out there right now in the midst of this
who have tuned out the noise and
actually focused on something
transcendent yeah it's kind of funny the
way we I can well funny you're
depressing I'm not sure the way we talk
about older people right like especially
remember remember in the first like week
of corona there were like all these blue
check Twitter people who were like oh
well you know just some old people are
gonna die and that's it and I just kept
thinking it's like oh my all my
grandparents are dead but I had a great
grandfather and a great grandmother for
a long time also it's like I love them I
always love being with them and like all
that and it's like well just old people
are gonna die and it's like you know
maybe we have something to learn from
old people you think that's possible
well look I mean that's I I reject the
old young line I don't think that's
quite it's it's a what do they call it
when the statistical causation is skewed
right like like when uh when ice cream
sales increase
rapes increase you can say causation and
what is it somebody's not causation that
thing right it's like just the relevant
a bit you know yeah obviously it's the
heat it's the heat that drives sexual
assault and ice cream sales it's it's
not those two things I don't I don't
know that your age is the reason you're
high risk
in and of itself I think these these
comorbidities are really fascinating and
you know I'm personally unless
interested in how old a person is if
they succumb to this disease then I'm
desperate to know though if they were
hypertensive
we're diabetic or fat or you know what
what are these other things and it is it
I mean I'm gonna say something that
taken out of context will get me creamed
out in the world but it's an honest
question here we go is it is it the co
vid did he or she die from the co vid or
was the covent the straw that broke the
camel's back you know I know there are
plenty of instances where the disease
killed an otherwise healthy person I
want to know that but I also really want
to know uh how many camels backs were
broken as a result of this because that
matters and it goes back to your earlier
question what else can you be doing when
you're cooped up and losing your mind
maybe you don't want to right how about
you walk six miles every morning I've
done it every day and I swear I've never
felt better it's a first thing I do I
get up and I dragged my poor dog out six
miles and and I'm trying to eat better
I'm trying to drink less you know these
are the things like why not incorporate
that into every fatal statistic that
pops up you know on the screen on every
single Channel I don't I don't care how
many are infected and how many have died
I want to I want the context and the
perspective I don't know what to do with
those numbers in a vacuum
except panic about it so I just wish
there were there were ways to and
this is why I enjoy this format you know
I can ramble I can I can zig I can zag
and maybe eventually land on something
cogent tough to do on Tucker even though
you know I like Tucker fine it's it's
just tough to do with Anderson Cooper
it's it's it's tough to be out there and
say something that is precisely what you
mean to say in the allotted time that
that doesn't come back over the net you
know with explanation points from some
other magazine that wants to take your
words to make a larger point well by the
way you'll I know you'll love this one
because Tucker walks into my house and
it's my garage and he opens up the door
and I'm sitting here and you know this
guy's he's the highest-paid Cable News
guy he's got you know gajillion dollars
whatever it's he's riding high he opens
the door he this is his exact quote when
he looks at my studio holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you did it good I've said the same thing
to each other look you did it 10 years
ago
you guys put your finger in the air and
felt which way the wind was blowing and
you you everybody now cable news looks
like your show you know it's hysterical
but longer
I had that I had a similar conversation
with him about the the unintended
consequences of production production is
the enemy of authenticity in my view and
I've that's why the production values on
shows like Dirty Jobs returning the
favour' all the stuff I work on hi I
always always always push back against
the desire to make them perfect because
what the viewer I think really wants
today is something authentic now there
was a time before we were in the age of
authenticity I guess it was the age of
authority and that's when all the
newscasters talked like this and that's
when everybody you know well they didn't
get that memo nobody cares anymore
people have stopped caring about that
stuff for years you know they don't care
that the anchors wearing makeup they
don't care that it's shot in HD they
don't care that there's a teleprompter
that by the way the anchors trying very
hard to pretend they're not reading from
I mean could could there be a greater
artifice like we want you to trust us
because we have information you need but
what prompter no I'm not reading from a
prompter this is all coming up there's
also no one talking in my ear as I'm
telling you the stuff that I'm just
thinking of at the moment even though
I'm talking like a robot
an authentic robot it's you know bait a
very authentic robot look I'd rather
watch a robot that looks like a robot
talking to me like a robot I'd be like
well there and I'm getting my news from
a robot that's okay but actually I do
know that's Wolf Blitzer for the record
but you know what do you remember it was
Walter Cronkite right
he had the glasses and he's sitting
there at the desk and we just landed on
the moon or maybe it was Kennedy who
would die but I think there's the
Kennedy one takes off the glasses and he
looks at the lens and he talks from his
heart and you know it's just every time
I see somebody doing that now who's
delivering the news I just see a
performance you know that wasn't a
performance that was Walter freaking
Cronkite delivering some very sad news
and doing it in a way that like you know
it's seared into my retina
man you've given me a lot here micro
yeah I think I should I think I could
have added like modern-day philosopher
to the intro at the beginning of this
thing
I prefer philosopher king but I don't
want to believe
I want to wrap this I want to wrap this
in a nice boat cuz you you sorta it's
interesting because it's like we come
from very very different worlds but
you've sort of hit like everything that
I've been thinking about and all the
things that I talk about on this show
and that that's why I love doing this
when I find someone who's like doing
some other stuff and yet yet actually
can make sense through the other stuff
so I guess I got a good one for you so
for all the stuff that we've talked
about here how do you think we actually
fix it and by it I mean the political
class that's broken the media class
that's broken the inauthentic
inauthentic class that is broken I mean
is it really just like a whole bunch of
us have to find whatever our dirty job
is and just do it and do it and do do it
until yeah is that it did I get it it's
yeah it's that it's that because look
we're in our own world here we're way
too inside to be dispensing advice you
know besides if we did you know how do
we know who's listening you know that's
the thing I wanted to riff on earlier
that we kind of talked around a little
bit but really yeah I mean not a day
goes by on my Facebook page when
somebody doesn't encourage me to
encourage six million people to go out
and vote right and I'm like well why
would I why would I do that
I don't know them I don't know how
they're going to vote I don't know if
they're informed I don't know
I don't think voting is a thing that you
ought to be persuaded to do I would know
or recommend somebody I didn't know
cast a vote then I would recommend they
buy a gun I you have the right to do it
but that in and of itself is not enough
for me personally micro to say hey so
take it from me get out there and vote
exercise your right to bear arms oh I
don't know who's listening so I I try
and stay at my lane with that kind of
stuff but to answer your question how
I for me it was it was an equal measure
of humility and discomfort
I had a pretty good career right up to
the point where I was willing to become
uncomfortable and then I had a great
career
you know I impersonated a host for 20
years on a lot of different shows and I
narrated everything if there was a
wildebeest trying to get across the vast
reaches of the barren Serengeti I was
telling you about it and it never works
out for the wildebeest Dave and said but
but dirty Collective editing it never
works out
never once no I mean sooner or later
they're all gonna get eaten you know
they're gonna stop they're thirsty they
put their face in there and the
crocodiles gonna get them and then the
hyenas gonna it's just it always always
happens this way so never leave the herd
alright that's the advice that one would
give visa V the wildebeest paradigm but
of course we're also talking about the
essential importance of leaving the herd
somebody has to go first
somebody always has to go first so man
I'm this is looks like a shotgun coming
back at you but the answer is we need a
parapet eeeh the Greek word for a
realization right we need a pretty and
parapet ia's or a form of a nag
norisse's and parapet ii azure that
moment in the narrative where we realize
everything we thought we knew was wrong
when Oedipus realizes the beautiful
woman he's sleeping with and having kids
with as his mother right it changed the
course of his of his narrative my little
life changed in a sewer in San Francisco
when I realized that I was a better
guest than I was a host and when I
looked at myself differently what Dave
I'm gonna put a bow on this the way few
of your guests ever have are you ready
bring it home row come on man to bring
this back to the very first question you
asked me how do I see myself I see
myself what did I tell you as a guest as
an avatar and a cipher prior to that I
saw myself strictly as a host and a
narrator that little adjustment
brought about by a very strange day in
the San Francisco sewers with a sewer
inspector and a little help from a rat
and a couple hundred metric tons of
human [ __ ] made me think differently
about how to work in television
the country needs a pair of putea we
need I think with a little humility and
a willingness to be uncomfortable to
reconsider our own deeply held beliefs
get out of our comfort zone try things
that we normally wouldn't try be open to
ideas and thoughts that we would
normally dismiss and and look at the
evidence that demands a verdict and be
skeptical you know look at Neil
Ferguson's model then look at John iein
Edie's and be okay with the fact that
sometimes experts with lots of initials
after their names are wrong doesn't mean
they're all wrong
it just means they're all human
row this is
do this show you did it you did it I
landed the player I'm not even gonna end
this in any sort of professional way
because professionalism is the old world
the new world is we just you know shoot
the [ __ ] until the camera stops so it it
has been a serious pleasure I hope we
can eventually do this in real life
maybe with masks maybe not and I look
forward to continuing the adventure with
you hey man if I ever attempt to follow
in your footsteps abused to be this
format you'll be my first guest but
until that great getting up morning I'm
coming to your garage as soon as the
authorities bless it if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell